thank you alex uh thank you for everyone
for for showing up here this morning uh
really just uh i'm excited to be here
really impressed with alex and the whole
team
i know you know i've never put on a
conference but i've participated in i
know this stuff is really hard so just
want to give credit kudos to you alex
and everybody that had something to do
with putting this on because since the
first moment alex reached out for me to
come and speak about the intersection of
cloud insecurity i've been impressed
with the professionalism uh to the
traveling to getting registered to the
party last night at city museum and to
all of this stuff so just uh really
kudos to you and it's great to be back
in person uh you know i'm very happy
that i'm not staring at a screen right
now and that i'm wearing pants uh which
is uh a little bit of a change here
right uh so uh again thank you alex
great job i want to just give you a
round of applause because this has been
awesome
so any uh any other first timers here
any any first time strange loopers here
me too so glad that i'm not alone there
too yeah let's give ourselves a round of
applause my first time in st louis first
time at strange loop extremely excited
to be just be speaking to you all today
about the intersection of cloud and
security and
really my goal today of this talk is to
kick off a conversation make sure that
as you go through all these rest of the
sessions today and tomorrow you go back
to your organizations we start to think
about security a little bit differently
we start to think about security earlier
on and wonder are we doing things uh
with the security mindset in place so i
don't expect everyone here to agree with
everything i have to say i don't expect
you to to do the things that i i might
try to demo here if the demo gods allow
me later on but i do hope that we
challenge some of these original ways
that you've been thinking about security
so let's let's go ahead and get into it
a little bit about myself i am the
founder and ceo of bite check and invite
check's a cyber security sas company
really with one focus
make compliance suck less
we all know compliance sucks at least i
do for sure and our goal is you know we
built an automated solution to to make
that process easier i sit on a few
boards spent some time in the u.s army
as a signal officer for a few years i
actually joined the army because i broke
both ankles playing basketball at
florida state
ended up
making it on the team and playing a
little bit so if anybody out there likes
college hoops or likes to talk about
college hoops let's let's meet out there
and have a good conversation
i teach a class that sans on continuous
automation and cloud compliance so
compliance is is my thing and uh you're
not here to hear about me so i'll i'll
go ahead and get right into this talk
by the way connect with me on all those
social platforms at aj on on all of
those definitely
so i can't give a talk about security
being the biggest benefit of the cloud
without talking about some of these
other benefits right we got to start
there about what are the other benefits
if you go out and do a google search of
cloud computing and why you're moving to
the cloud
this is what you're going to see listed
right you're going to hear about the
cost savings and
i get a little bit of ptsd when i when i
hear about cost savings because i
learned everything that i know about the
cloud just poking around and tinkering
and i definitely got that one build at
one time when i left too many resources
running and uh i did not think the cloud
was about cost savings when that
happened um for sure
but as a small business owner as a you
know startup founder definitely i save a
lot of money running my workload in the
cloud it's a lot easier i don't have to
guess
my capacity i don't have to worry about
am i going to need to pre-purchase a lot
of things i kind of can do that on an
on-demand basis and that's a huge
benefit we obviously can move fast right
we can do things in a faster manner we
can scale faster it's really elastic and
that's one of the benefits of the cloud
that kind of infinite storage that you
have there
and of course we're no longer spending
money on running our data centers i know
as a compliance guy i used to walk
around into those physical data centers
and look at the raised floors check the
check the cabinets do those long
walk-throughs looking at all the cameras
luckily we don't have to do that no more
you know amazon google microsoft they
they all do that for us which is which
is really great but
there's something missing here right uh
there's just one element missing and
it's security uh and you know you're
probably like aj this is you titled your
talk why security is the biggest benefit
of the cloud and you didn't even list
security as a benefit on the slide i did
that on purpose um that wasn't wasn't a
mistake
and really it's because that's what
you're gonna see
if you go out there and look and see
what are the benefits of the cloud what
are the reasons why i want to use cloud
computing generally you're not going to
run into anyone saying security is that
thing security is the thing that's going
to be a big huge aspect of you getting
into into cloud computing and
i think that's for a few reasons right
uh number one is business
most companies i'm sure most of your
companies out there unless you're a
cyber security software company or cyber
security business
you're not in the business of security
you're not doing security for your
business so moving fast being able to
get new features out to your customers
being able to save money being able to
reduce the operational overhead of all
the things that you're doing to run your
your workloads that's a business driver
and the business is obviously going to
drive a lot of these conversations so i
think security is often left out i think
security and those kind of drivers
around speed are often seen as opposing
forces which i don't necessarily agree
with i i think security actually can
speed you up especially if you started
earlier on in your process earlier on in
your pipeline you can eliminate a lot of
rework eliminate a lot of
manual labor by some of the security
teams if you do it earlier but that's
another talk for another conference
around security and speed
but you know the other reason i think
that we don't hear about security
is because
you often hear folks talking about
security in the cloud as if it's way
different than security not in the cloud
you know they're
things are called differently obviously
and and i think that's fair
but when we think about it at its core
some of the core security concepts the
basics you know you want to protect your
identities you want to make sure that
you understand your perimeter and
protect from outside sources outside of
that boundary you want to identify
vulnerabilities you want to respond to
them
those are all simple concepts that apply
regardless of where you're running your
workload right this is something that is
going to be important to you and i think
that mindset of oh security is just
really different it just goes get put on
a shelf
and those challenges are just kind of
stuck out there and they're like oh
we'll think about that later we're going
to worry about the cost benefits we're
going to worry about scalability we're
going to worry about all these other
things that drive the business and that
security stuff's a little bit different
in the cloud so let's just move that
over there
and i think that starts really with when
you're building your applications or if
you're migrating to the cloud and
there's these concepts that you'll hear
about
these seven r's that aws says or gartner
released back in 2011 5rs
and
i'll just do a quick uh disclaimer here
i'm gonna say a lot about aws
i don't work for aws they don't know who
i am um and they don't need any more
marketing for me i think they're solid
there but that's just where i built bike
check that's where i carved out my
experience so a lot of the things that i
reference will be related to aws but
they apply to those other cloud
providers uh this is not a an aws
marketing talk it's just what i know so
that's where we're gonna we're gonna go
but these seven are there's five here
aws has a couple other ones that are
about not moving to the cloud so it
doesn't make a ton of sense but i think
the what i normally see as i'm talking
to customers that are getting into the
cloud
that are trying to build workloads on
the cloud maybe spin up a new
application in the cloud i see this
rehost method i see this lift and shift
where i'm going to take this oracle
database i have and i'm just going to go
throw it on the ec2 instance in the
cloud i'm not going to try to do it in a
cloud native way i'm not thinking about
it any differently i'm just like hey
like cool i'm going to go run this in
the in the cloud the same exact way i'm
running it in another environment or the
same exact way i used to i used to do
this and i don't think that's the right
answer you know i think what we should
see and when we'll start to see more
conversations about security is if we
refactor or re-architect
if we're thinking about how can i
redesign this in a cloud-native way to
take advantage of all of these cool
technologies and services that are there
that i can really start to do things
differently maybe i don't need to expose
my bastion hosts out to the internet
anymore because of some of the things
that you can do on these cloud providers
maybe i don't need to run that workload
exactly the same way i can run that
oracle database on aurora in the cloud
and take advantage of some of the things
that they do from an elastic elastic and
a scalability perspective so i think
this is really where we get it wrong
early on it's a mindset shift it's a
thinking
thinking about things as you're thinking
about moving to the cloud and it's
a lot of it like i said before it's
because we don't think of security as a
benefit we're not saying like hey this
is something that can solve some of the
problems that i know i have from a
modern security perspective
and a few of the modern security
challenges that we see out there that i
see all the time
that
apply regardless of where you're hosted
whether that's cloud whether that's
on-prem whether whatever you're doing
you're still going to want to know
there goes my top to my water
you're still going to want to know where
your resources at what's going on in
your environment can i see who's doing
what do i have control over that do i
know what they're doing where they're
going and how they're going about it you
want to be able to respond to events you
want to be able to identify an event and
then respond to that and do that as fast
as possible and eliminate that time
between detection and response
with the ever increasing perimeter in
our modern environments that's a concern
of a lot of folks in the security space
it's how do i know what my boundary is
you know you used to be able just to
draw a line around your boundary throw
up a network diagram and say hey this is
this is the boundary of my network this
is the boundary of my environment really
difficult to do now in these in these
really distributed environments and that
increasing perimeter is a concern that
attack surface is just continuing to
explode and that's a modern security
challenge
of course i'm a compliance guy so i got
to talk a little bit about compliance
right and obviously you know i know
there's somebody here groaning they
might have threw up in their mouth when
i said compliance
and i get it i i 100 get it you know we
often hear compliance is not security
100 agree you can achieve a compliance
certification without being secure you
can pull that wool over your auditor's
eyes you can trick them i can show you
how uh but
i do believe security is compliance if
we just flip that saying around and we
focus on those basics we focus on some
of these things and we focus on security
you're going to meet those compliance
frameworks i don't care which one it is
they they all say the same thing whether
fedramp iso sock 2 pci they're all
really saying the same thing it's just a
matter of who you're paying that's
different and if you focus on security
and we say security is compliance
you're going to be able to achieve those
and i know a lot of csos out there they
have a million compliance frameworks
that they're trying to comply with
and their solution generally is let's
just throw another sas solution at it
let's just get another sas solution out
there and
you know i don't know
i i obviously make my money off of
selling a sas solution so i'm kind of
taking money out of my mouth right now
but i don't think that you need another
sas solution to solve these security
problems a lot of these things you can
do in a cloud-native way
without throwing a bunch of tools at it
i run into i just recently was talking
to a company a few few weeks ago they
have four different sas solutions that
do the same exact thing
they're not using any of them i'm just
like what are we doing here why are we
doing those and you probably can do this
right on the cloud
and that's where today i'm going to
really talk about how we can solve some
of these problems some of these
challenges in our in our environments in
a cloud-native way in a manner where
we're taking advantage of those services
we're doing some refactoring
re-architecting to say how can i
leverage what's already built on these
cloud providers
that will allow me to handle some of
these security challenges how can i use
that that intersection of all of the
resources that are there from a cloud
perspective and improve the security of
my environment and do it at scale
i think about a lot of myself you know
running uh the the bike check
application
without the cloud the stuff that we're
able to do from a security perspective
would not be possible i'm a really small
we're a really small company under 10
folks uh not a lot of people with hands
on keyboards most days
so it's been really challenging if i
wasn't automating things and leveraging
a lot of these services to help protect
our application and protect our
customers data
so when we talk about security in the
cloud you'll you'll see here that i
capitalize this end and that's really
because of the shared responsibility
model which i'm sure a lot of you have
heard of where the cloud providers are
responsible for the security of the
cloud you know they're going to be
responsible for the physical side the
environmental side all of those physical
data center checks that i used to do we
no longer have to do
amazon microsoft google are going to
handle that for you you no longer have
to go in there and check that stuff up
so they're responsible for the security
of the cloud but when it comes to the
security in the cloud that's on you
that's where that first kind of myth of
i don't know i don't have a lot of
control over what's going on in the
cloud
we got to push back on that because that
is on you you still have to control who
has access you still can say where that
data goes you still have to say what
those people can do with that data and
you get to see that at scale you get
that visibility and control really at
scale in the cloud that might be really
challenging elsewhere especially when
you think about this increasing
perimeter folks continuing to deploy
resources pretty easily
that can explode fast and you want to be
able to see those things and i think
it's really challenging to do without
automation or without some of these real
these integrated services
over the next few slides before we hop
into a quick demo i'm going to share
some resources and again another
disclaimer matt fuller who wrote this
article and then other folks that i'm
going to share
i don't think they know who i am
but i'm just sharing some resources that
i found very helpful as i've learned
about some of these things and matt
wrote this article i think is the
founder of of cloud sport uh that talks
about how to enable login on every aws
service when you when you hear logging
on aws you typically think of cloudtrail
that's going to go out there and see all
of the api activity from either a user a
resource or or really anything on aws
but there's so much more
you can log a lot with each individual
service and oftentimes people don't even
turn that on they only think of
cloudtrail and they're thinking of those
missing uh those missing information
that they would want but it's available
if you just can dive deep into those
details of what should be logged and for
for those i see some folks writing some
stuff down i'm going to hop into my
slack channel and drop some of the
resources that i'm sharing so no
pressure if you if you don't capture
this down and are able to get this but
i'll drop all of these resources the
links in there
in the in that slack channel
so when it comes to visibility and
control
i actually think it's stronger in the
cloud you get to see things that you
probably wouldn't have been able to see
elsewhere unless you either wrote
something yourself
use some other 10 other sas tools
together to get all this information
but you can do this natively on the
cloud and then have all of those
services talk to each other and that's
where we really start to see these
benefits right when we start to use
these deeply integrated services and we
say okay i know that this tool is out
here or this this resource is out here
doing this i can see the user that's
doing it i can see what they're doing i
know my policies say that's not good let
me go and fix that let me go and make
sure that that's fixed because that's a
known weakness that's a known
vulnerability that i can that i can
address and that's where we really start
to see
the power of the cloud is because we can
improve that detection and response
there's a metric that i
often check in compliance and then also
an incident response mttr the mean time
to respond where you want to
dramatically have that number go down
you want to have the number the time
between detection and response
you want that number to go down you want
it to be a shorter time frame really
because you don't want bad actors to
take advantage of it but your teams a
lot of the things i think about when
alex was here talking about people
that was really important because that's
what i think about behind these metrics
behind these technologies behind these
tools there's individuals there's
somebody that's going out there and
trying to fix these things and spending
their time and we should be thinking as
technologists as leaders as whatever
your role is
how can i reduce that time that that
person is doing these manual repetitive
tasks
all of us all of you here in this room
your your organizations didn't hire you
to do repetitive tasks they hired you to
think
this is a room full of really smart
people and you weren't hired just to
repeat and do things that probably could
be automated away but oftentimes
organizations leave especially security
up for some kind of manual check you
know you have somebody that says i'm
going to i know that i don't want none
of my s3 buckets to be public but i'm
still going to let people do it and then
when it happens i'm going to have
somebody go out and fix that
doesn't make a ton of sense when you can
let that person who you now are saying
you don't have to worry about that we're
going to automate that away we're going
to detect this issue we're going to
respond to it rapidly we're going to fix
it and hey we'll send you a notification
you go out and think be proactive be
proactive when it comes to these
security things because that's what's
needed in security security is really
especially compliance as well it's just
really a reactive process it's we're
reacting to things which you kind of
have to because the threats change on a
day-to-day basis
but we can get more proactive especially
in the cloud using these deeply
integrated services and i'll give an
example here
so we all probably have heard of s3
buckets if you do a google search of s3
bucket breaches you'll go down a rabbit
hole of and just be kind of baffled by
all of the organizations that have
experienced this uh
and it really frustrates me uh there's
not a lot of justification you know i've
i've heard some solid arguments for
public s3 buckets uh you're gonna it's
gonna take a lot to convince me
that that's needed in a production
environment with sensitive data
so there's really no reason to allow
this weakness to happen there's no
reason that a user an individual
human should have to go out and check
this stuff on a regular basis and this
is where it looks like i had some a
mashup up there on aws config from my
google slides to powerpoint transfer
which is which is par for the course but
uh
this is where you can do this on in the
cloud so we can use something like aws
config to say hey i only want my buckets
in this production account to be private
and i want them to be encrypted at rest
i don't really care who creates them i
don't really care uh what the reason is
if there's a bucket created it needs to
be encrypted at rest and it doesn't need
to be public
and config will say all right great
every time a new bucket's created i'm
going to check that and if not i'm going
to spin up up that green arrow using aws
systems manager and i'm going to
automatically remediate it i'm going to
automatically fix this without you
having to call in a human so this is
where we start to talk about like human
free zones which i talk a lot about in
with with folks in security is how are
we building these areas of your
application how are we building areas in
your organization when it comes to
security that we can eliminate humans so
that they can go out and do proactive
threat hunting so they can go out and
figure out and see some of these signals
for when something bad is about to
happen
and aws this aws config will go out
they'll fix it they'll send a message
you know so instead of at 4am that
engineer getting woken up by a pager
duty alert they're able to stay asleep
um they get a little message that says
hey this happened johnny spun up a
public bucket last night
but we fixed it already you might want
to go talk to johnny about what's going
on there and why they're doing it and
it's a really powerful way you know this
is a rudimentary solution but
there are hundreds i think hundreds now
of aws config rules that are pre-built
that can go out and say here are some
basic security things that i know i
don't want to happen in my environment
let me
make sure that i check for this on a
regular basis but then if i see that it
happened i don't want to just scream
about it i don't want to just send
another alert to slack i want to go out
and fix it i want to go out and actually
remediate it and that's where we can
reduce that detection and response time
and now if there's aws config rules that
you have or things that you have in your
organization there's not a rule for the
cool thing is you can write your own
and you can write your own remediation
as well
actually before
i think maybe nine months or so ago
config released a lot of these auto
remediation rules before you had to
write your own remediation using like a
lambda function which was really simple
but
now they do it for you it's super easy
you just a few clicks or a few lines of
code there you have these auto
remediation set to where you're able to
fix things that you identify in a pretty
streamlined manner and what i want to do
quickly and i'm going to attempt the
demo gods here um i'm going to create a
bucket here while we're while we're in
this in this talk
and we're going to let config in this
test account that i have do its thing
and i should have
mirrored this so that i'm not looking up
at the screen
strange loop we'll call it strange loop
grand
and i'm gonna do it with this strange
loop account that i created
all right so let me grab that so we have
a bucket created and and when we talk
about increasing perimeter this is this
is the problem right
with a couple couple couple little
commands there i'm able to
create a new resource and let's check
and see did i create it according to my
company's policies did i create this
bucket with the right bucket encryption
and server side encryption configuration
is not found
which which is which is expected because
i didn't set any of those
parameters when i launched this let's
just let's just check public access and
for those that don't know if your bucket
is publicly accessible anyone with a aws
account can access that bucket
uh anyone that any bad actor if there's
if there's any sensitive data in their
credit cards pii et cetera they can go
out and get that anyone with an aws
account so anyone today right now can go
on aws and spin up a free tier account
and then if you have some skills you can
go out and just do a quick query and
find all the public s3 buckets and find
some sensitive data and that's what
those breaches you'll see out there are
literally someone just did this they
just created a bucket through some
credit cards threw some pii in there and
said oh just whoever wants it can get it
uh and and they did
they did go and get it uh so we're gonna
let config do its thing in the
background here as we continue talking
and when we pop back in we'll see if
those settings have changed on those
buckets and and we'll see if the demo
gods are in our favor
so next up talk about reducing the
attack surface right
this is something that i hear often that
i just it baffles me where we're talking
about the perimeter we're talking about
man it's it's going to be really
difficult for me to
to manage this entire cloud you know we
have all of these regions i think over
18 regions now in aws and similar
numbers on azure
what if i have users that are creating
stuff in eu what if i have users that
are creating stuff in
u.s west and i only want to be in u.s
east 1 or u.s east 2. the cool thing
with the cloud is you don't have to just
have the entire cloud as your
environment you can dramatically reduce
this attack surface using a concept that
all of you probably familiar with here
guard rails
where you can say i'm only going to
allow certain things to happen in
certain areas and on aws the way that
you would do this is with a service
called aws organizations where you can
segment out accounts and this is really
the recommended way to run your
workloads in aws if you're not running a
multi-count workload
for you know a single application not
multiple applications but for a single
application you're probably doing it
wrong because the blast radius of a
potential bad event or incident
it dramatically grows when you put
everything in one account
so with aws organizations you can
segment these accounts out by business
use case or or business need
and it really allows you to limit when
something bad happens and i'll walk you
through what we have here so at the top
there you have your main account that's
where your finance folks are going to be
that's where all your bills go and
really nothing else should be there
there should be no resources there
should be no users it should really just
be that finance team
you're going to have a security account
this is where all your logs will go this
is where all of your security team will
live in and really no one else should
have access to that no one else should
be in there doing anything messing with
those logs be able to modify those and
that should really be segmented off
when i talk about limiting the blast
radius
the people account that you see up there
in the security ou you see an account
next to the people next to that
security account that's where you can
really limit a blast radius and here's a
really simple example you have a user
for some reason that user doesn't have
multi-factor authentication enabled
their account is compromised
i'm a bad actor i hop into this account
here
and i'm looking around i'm like alright
i'm in what am i going to do let me
start figuring out what are the
resources and i'm getting access to nod
every time i try to describe ec2
instances or describe databases or
whatever it may be
and the reason is is because in this
account where you have users there's no
resources the only thing that that user
can do is use identity and access
management and sts or security token
service to roll switch into these other
accounts
you don't have to have any resources in
the same account where your users are
and that's how you limit the blast
radius right if something bad happens if
my account is compromised the bad actor
comes in and they hop into a conference
room imagine if you came in here early
and there's nobody in here the bad
actors in your account they're looking
around like there's nothing here what am
i doing why am i in this account there's
nothing here because everything else are
on these other accounts and the way that
you set those protections around those
accounts are called service control
policies or scps where you basically are
able to put these guard rails around the
account
really there's no limit to the things
that you can reduce you know you can say
i only want these users using these
specific services i only want these
folks working out of u.s east one if i
know there's no reason for my team or me
to be hosting or doing stuff in other
regions us west 2 or eu
i can say only work in u.s east one
if you're an administrator you have god
level access even if you have all of
that access you still can't do anything
unless you're in that region and and
you're really reducing that perimeter
your team doesn't have to worry about is
someone spinning up resources in this
other region and then you find out when
you get that bill at the end of the
month that you have some rds instances
out in a in the u.s west and i
chuckled because that recently happened
to me
in a little test environment that i was
doing for a workshop but
really cool way to limit things you can
say don't disable any security services
you can i want to make sure that
guard duties enabled security hubs
enabled all these other services are
enabled and no one else can disable them
you can say i only want a certain type
of ec2 instance or rds instance deployed
so we think about configuration
management you can do use scps here that
reduce that attack surface and there's
really two really good resources that i
would recommend to you all as you're
thinking about some of these concepts of
guard rails and and reducing that attack
surface
the first is this aws security road map
by scott piper and if you i highly
recommend following scott on twitter a
super great follow but this road map
right here if you've inherited an aws
account if you're doing anything in the
security world or you're thinking about
moving to the security world and you're
hosting on aws
this is literally your roadmap this will
tell you step by step what is what right
looks like if you are setting up an aws
account from scratch getting security
right and you see there on stage six
scott talks about
the reducing that attack surface and he
gets into aws organizations he suggests
a little bit of a different method of
those aws accounts that i've shown but
those concepts the same
reduce that blast radius segment out
your accounts by business need or
business justification and you're going
to set yourself up for success so this
is a really valuable document highly
recommend anyone that's getting into aws
security or it has to do with aws
security to follow scott and then also
get this
this screenshot here is also another
resource
from a site called cloud sec docs from
marco lancini he also produces a weekly
newsletter that's really great but these
scps i talked about service control
policies he's already wrote a bunch of
them that you can literally just go to
his site copy and paste and go out and
implement immediately in your
environment so things like not being
able to disrupt guard duty and root
accounts not being able to do anything
you can apply on certain accounts to
make sure that you're protecting from
that not being able to create im access
keys you may have in that production
environment where your application is
there should be no users and no hard no
no permanent or persistent access keys
right so you can do that from an scp
perspective and say i no longer want
this to happen you no longer can can can
create access keys in our account and
these scps really put those nice guard
rails around your account so now your
teams don't have to worry about
is something bad gonna happen that i
know i don't want to happen we can just
eliminate that from the scratch as we
segment out these accounts and apply
these these scps across the board
so cloudsec docs from marco
scott piper's aws security roadmap
really powerful resources and i'll
actually show an example here as we pop
back into the the cli to show you the
region the region example so
i'm going to go back and check this same
bucket that we just created a little bit
ago um and hopefully there we go we're
now true you know we're we're now the
demo gods are in our favor yeah thank
you
i was a little you know
you probably saw my heart beating uh so
the demo gods are in our favor we we now
config went out and did his thing you
know i'm just sitting here having a
conversation with you
and a misconfiguration that i know is
bad that i know is causing an issue and
could potentially be really really bad
for our organization is fixed and
there's a message being sent off to
slack saying hey aj's doing bad things
you might want to go talk to them you
might want to go figure out what's going
on let's check the encryption really
quick
and there we go we got aes256 we're
doing the right things
and again like this is a very simple
example and you can get extremely
complex with config rules you can write
your own you can write your own
remediation you can write your own
notification maybe you don't want to
auto remediate you know maybe you want
to just scream at someone about it and
do some other things maybe put it in the
sandbox or something and you can do that
as well but
it's just
it's it's a pet peeve of mine when we
constantly see these these
vulnerabilities these breaches happen
for things that are avoidable uh things
that you can you can really eliminate
that risk from materializing by reducing
that time between detection and response
and now let's talk about those those
scps really quick so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to go out and try to
take a look at some of the ec2 instances
that i have and i'll do this in us east
one
and i have another account
strange loop region
you'll be able to see uh there's this
ec2 instance i created a couple days ago
for this talk that i'm able to get that
and i'm going to run that same command
i'm just going to change the region
we're going to go and say can i see the
ec2 instances in usb2 and i'm not
allowed to perform that operation
i still have the same permissions i'm
still an administrator still have access
to the same account the only thing i
changed was the region that's that
service control policy that's the that's
where you can say look there's no reason
for you to be in usc 2. i don't even
want you looking at ec2 instances over
there i don't want you doing anything
over there i don't want you creating
access keys and that's why service
control policies are so powerful when we
talk about reducing that attack service
when we talk about being able to limit
the blast radius of things and putting
those guard rails around accounts this
is something that you can do that now we
can eliminate a lot of that manual labor
we can eliminate a lot of those issues
that come up and are taking away
people's time you're sending out that
security engineer hey go clean up my aws
account i found that i had
resources in seven different regions
that don't belong i need you to go clean
that up and figure out what's going on
not needed anymore when you use these
scps
which is which is really powerful and
one thing that i want to just
talk about with service control policies
the way that they work uh you have your
identity and access management policy
that says uh aj is an admin he can do
all of these things in aws he has uh you
know god level access to do all of these
things that service control policy is
applied on top of it that says
yes you have all of that access yes you
are an administrator but you can only do
things in these parameters those guard
rails go on top of it so that's really
where your permissions and the service
control policies come into play is that
sweet spot right there in the middle
where the service control policy is not
going to say you're allowed to do x y
and z that's a mistake often see you
know we see folks create user accounts
they're like i'm not giving that person
any permissions and then i'm going to
apply an scp on top of it
they're not going to nothing's going to
work you're not going to be able to do
anything the person still needs iam
permissions but the service control
policies put that guard rail around it
that say i can't go out and do things
even if i'm an administrator if i'm in
u.s east 2 can't do it can only do those
same activities in u.s east 1. so really
really powerful and as we think about
our people as we think about the people
behind these metrics the people behind
these vulnerabilities and these falls
we have to get security folks security
engineers back to doing what they were
hired to do
thinking
being proactive
not responding and doing manual
repetitive things that could be avoided
if we're doing if we're applying these
guard rails if we're thinking about
security in a cloud-native way
so to wrap up here you know we often
hear a lot about devsecops and uh i know
it's a buzzword in a lot of circles and
a lot of folks are starting to not like
that word it's kind of
transition like zero trust to to just
become a buzzword but it's real you know
devsecops is real and we should be
thinking about it but when i think about
devsecops i'm not thinking about tools
and technology i'm not thinking about
all these processes i'm thinking about
the mentality i'm thinking about the
mindset i'm thinking about the culture
shift at an organization to where
security is talked about and brought up
early on
and we have to start asking these
questions are we thinking about security
early on are we having the necessary
conversations early on in our process of
either migrating an application building
out a new feature whatever it may be are
we asking about security early on and
this doesn't have to be security
professionals you know security is
really a team sport because oftentimes
if it's a bad security organization
folks are hiding from security you know
if security is seen as a blocker to the
organization
we're going to work around it we're
going to figure out our way to do other
things to get what we have to get done
but that's because security is not
brought on early on the process so a
challenge here for for you all is you
know ask about security early on talk
about security you don't have to be a
security engineer you don't have to be a
security professional to bring this
stuff up and to think about and say hey
are we are we leveraging all of the
things that are available to us
to do things the right way from a
security perspective
the other question and and you know i've
just kind of repeated this but how are
the tools the technologies the processes
how are they improving the quality of
life of our people
we have to eliminate this need for
this industry to
be
burned out to be thought of with what we
do for a living
it doesn't make any sense you know we
don't have to burn out to be successful
we don't have to
you know eliminate our time with our
families and ignore our health do all of
these things that we constantly see in
the industry
just because we work in tech
you know we can think about how to
improve the quality of life of not only
ourselves but people around us by asking
ourselves what are the tools and
technologies and the processes that
we're having in place and how is that
impacting someone downstream yes it may
enable you to move a little bit faster
to do things in one way but who else is
that going to impact later on
is there a way that you can make this
process easier for them
and improve their quality of life
because at the end of the day behind
these tools behind all these
technologies it's just us it's just
regular folks like this uh that are that
are interested in googling all day and
trying hard
and and we are the ones behind this and
we have to really really i think in the
future of this new hybrid work
environment that we're moving into
the quality of life for people the the
culture of organizations the way that
people are treated is going to be way
more important than any of the
technologies or tools or processes that
we can put in place and if we start to
think about security early on if we
start to think about some of these
concepts early on we may just make the
lives better of those folks that are
behind some of these metrics and tools
and processes
i want to just
challenge another concept that i that i
as you leave here and you know again i
mentioned i wanted this to start a
conversation and kick off things as
you're going throughout the rest of the
day into some of these really great
talks that are coming up
security and speed are not opposing
forces we don't have to pick one you
don't have to pick
speed over security or security over
speed
we can do both we can move fast and we
can do it in a secure manner and you can
do it with guardrails you can do it with
automating detection and response you
can do it with building security earlier
on in the process and having
conversations about security and
shifting the mindset where security is
not an afterthought
and then lastly automate everything you
know i'm a fairly lazy guy
so i'm gonna try to automate things as
much as possible i'll probably spend six
hours trying to automate something that
probably takes me two hours to actually
complete
just so i don't have to spend that two
hours later on but wherever we can
automate so that our security folks so
that we can get back to doing what we
are hired to do
which is to think which is to be
proactive
which is to use our skill sets to
identify potential weaknesses and
vulnerabilities in the future
but also just be able to to to
operate in a manner that's not
repetitive and draining on an individual
because i'm doing things that can that
are already preventing the known
weaknesses
so
i had a lot of fun with this
presentation i i want to leave with a
few thoughts uh the first being uh we're
hiring at bike check so uh if you uh
i know there's a lot of engineers here
uh i'm looking for some leaders i'm
looking for some junior folks so if
you're interested in making compliance
suck less let's let's have a
conversation and and building some cool
things and doing it in a manner where uh
you as a person will be cared about more
so than what you do for a living uh the
second thing that i like to to mention
tonight and i just have i cannot
do a talk without uh without mentioning
this is we often hear about a cyber
security skill shortage we often hear
about a talent shortage in the industry
uh which you know it may be true uh but
i think the only reason the way that we
fill this the only way that we solve a
lot of the security problems we need
more people and the way that we do that
is by hiring more diverse candidates we
need to hire more women we need to hire
more minorities and we need to look
around and challenge what are our hiring
practices i don't think there's a
pipeline problem i think there's enough
qualified people out there that are
minorities and women we just have to
look around and say where are we going
to find these folks are we still going
to the same places are we just asking
everybody in our organization to do
referrals and they go back to their own
networks and and we can change that and
i think it just takes each individual to
ask the question
to look around in their shops and say
are we doing things are we thinking
about diversity are we thinking about
hiring more women and minorities because
it's important especially in the cyber
security industry not just from what it
looks like but diversity of thought is
important to protect our environment and
protect our applications
so
thank you
that concludes my talk i wanted to
finish up early so that we can get these
walls up for the next talks i i had a
ton of fun i hope to chat with all of
you and and have some conversations over
the next few days and i hope that you
leave this and think about security a
little bit differently and figure out
ways that you can do things differently
in your environment i'll be active on
the slack channel if there's any
questions or concerns and i'll be
hanging out here but thanks everyone for
attending and getting up early this
morning to listen to me and i really
appreciate the opportunity strange loop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]